Today's show is all about besties,
which is why I'm here with Cameron Diaz
and Ross Matthews.
And every single person in our audience is a bestie.
You know, I think there's nothing better
than trying something new with a bestie.
Remember when we did scuba diving with sharks.
Yeah, or jumped out of an airplane.
Yeah.
Well, Drew and I were inspired by that.
We tried something new.
You may have seen a group called the Aqualillies.
They're a group of synchronized swimmers.
They were in the Cohen Brothers, Hail Caesar!,
Justin Bieber's Beauty And The Beat,
or even Beyonce's Black Is King.
Yeah, they're amazing.
Well, they really, they had their work cut out for them
when Drew and I tried to show up in their pool.
Take a look at this.
We.
Love.
The.
Drew.
Barrymore.
Show.
(women clapping)
How are you?
We're so excited.
I didn't get a bikini wax.
Me either.
So today you're going to be joining
our Aqualillies team.
We are gonna start by teaching you guys
how to do some basic floating skills.
I have strong core values,
but not a strong core.
Oh Wow.
Guys, don't forget to plank.
Yes.
You're doing it.
Nice job you guys.
Thank God we got pedicures.
We're gonna turn and do a pinwheel with our legs.
The way you turn is you just like
push the water away from you, basically.
I kayak, so I've,
Yeah, it's the same concept.
Whoo!
Drew!
(women cheering)
Whoa!
I am a Pisces.
Yes!
(all cheering)
I'm going to accept all of that applause.
Let's try this.
We want to turn halfway so that
our feet are facing out where our head was before.
Make sense?
Ish.
And, turn two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight.
Good job.
There we go.
Oh my God, I got lost.
No, perfect.
You just keep turning?
I just kept like, paddling.
Panic paddling.
Yes.
I think we're ready to learn the final skill.
The back tuck somersault.
We are all gonna disappear underwater at the same time.
I'll try to do it slow.
Oh wow.
That was slow, by the way.
Cool, I know, I know.
Okay.
(buzzer sound)
(Ross laughing)
Sorry Drew.
I'm like Ross, I don't have a core, apparently.
(buzzer sound)
Something happened.
Spread your knees a bit.
(buzzer sound)
You did great.
Why is this so hard?
It's like impossible.
We need to do...
Core workouts behind the desk.
By the way, I just heard about a machine
where you sit in a chair and it
reenacts like thousands of kegels for women
who have had children and things like that.
I'd still try it.
I think I need that chair right now.
So quick question.
Is there anything easier than that?
Let's try an oyster.
I like oysters.
We are gonna start on our back
and then we're gonna fold and disappear underwater.
So you're saying the key is to just sink.
Done.
(everyone cheering)
I can do it.
How do you put this thing on?
Kind of slip it over your nose, like that.
Oh, that's fun.
And it makes my voice even more annoying.
I'm gonna help you a little bit, if that's okay.
Just, you should really just shut me down.
Honestly, do I look cute though?
Yes.
Weirdly it like matches the flowers.
It does.
= We need focus ladies.
Okay, ready?
One, two, three, go.
(everyone laughing)
Drop your butt and get your knees up,
and before you know it,
it feels like you could do anything.
Okay, okay.
Like, that's the key move.
All right.
And then you're free.
Enough about your dating life.
Circle up.
Splash.
Five, six, seven, eight.
Drop our right ear, and we're gonna kick around.
Kick two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight.
I think I had the count wrong.
This is quick.
Yeah, I was gonna say,
much quicker than I, okay.
And the five, six, seven, eight, it's a five.
Five.
Are we ready to do this from the top?
(bright music)
Good job team!
This was so fun.
(women cheering)
There's only one spot left on the team, right?
So which one of us gets it?
(everyone laughing)
(audience applauding)
Right?
Well, that's one way to cool off.
I think Ross and I found a new pool party trick.
And we want to thank the Aqualillies
who are such good friends and
so supportive to each other
as an amazing group of women.
They're so capable and cool.
They're synchronized you guys.
That's the whole point.
That's like the next level best friend.
And can I just say, Drew and I are naturals.
Thank you so much.
Yeah.
(theme music)